Okay. Thanks. Is the microphone good? Yep. All right. So I'll just start with a quick introduction
about what these technologies are that I'll talk about a little bit about. But actually
most of the talk will be much more general. It's ended up being a bit more of an opinion
piece. So, which I actually often find more useful and interesting than talks about,
you know, the fine-grained details of some library. So, for the last few years I've been
developing this open-source library spacey. And this really sprung out of the need that
I saw for a library that took the types of results which were rapidly being generated
in academia and that I was working on at the time and made them more accessible for industry.
And then, since soon after we launched that, I ended up co-founding a company within
us, Montani, called Explosion AI. So in addition to the library spacey, we have a machine
learning library that we use with it, I'll call it Think, and an annotation tool
prodigy. And soon enough we'll have a data store of pre-trained models that will be providing
one alongside spacey as well. So as a sort of quick bio, this is Matthew and that's my
co-founder in us. And we're basically, you know, together most pretty much all of Explosion
AI. So we're a very small company based here in Berlin that really just does a commercial
open-source software. So there's the open-source library and then this commercial tool on top,
the annotation tool prodigy. So the way that we often explain the sort of structure of
these things, and you know, I guess we do this in an Explanant, like I'm five, or often
Explanant, like I'm seeing your management, the analogy that we use is like a boutique
kitchen. So the free recipes is kind of like the open-source software. And then we started
off doing consulting to support ourselves. But then we've since switched over to this
sort of line of gadgets, which is this prodigy and other extensions as well. And soon
we'll have premium ingredients that we're selling with this.
Okay, so to move into the talk proper, I'll start with this assertion. So the assertion
here is that natural language processing projects are like startups, so they fail a lot.
And so this is presented without, you know, I'm not going to be pretend scientific and
give you like some survey or something, but we have seen this. And to give you a bit
of an intuition for why this should be true or to make it seem a little bit more obvious
to you, imagine what the world would look like if NLP projects were not failing regularly.
Because human language is the, you know, basically the world's information system, this
really underpins a lot of commercial activity all over the place, right? And so if it were
true that these things didn't fail often, if it were true that we could easily automate
a lot of the work that happens in back offices and that sort of underpins this economic activity,
we would be seeing a far, far greater upswell in growth of the natural language processing
projects. And instead we do see like plenty of growth in NLP as we do with other
AI technologies, but it's nothing like what we would see if this were actually just easy,
and if everything just worked out of the box. So, and you know, additionally, if you use these
technologies like translate or interactive chat applications or search or summarization things,
you'll see that these technologies are far from perfect. And so there's this little dance that
needs to be done to map those imperfections and get those imperfect technologies delivering
useful enough value to justify a commercial investment. And when this works, it works
fantastically well. And so there's some projects which basically return the fund like they say
for startups where, you know, a few projects are wildly successful, but then there's still a lot of
failures. So now the question is what drives that frequency of failure and how can we avoid it and
how can we do better? And in particular how can we make sure that your project isn't one of the
ones that fail? Well, okay, so to consider this we can flip the question on its head and say,
all right, what would we, what would it look like if we wanted to maximize the project's risk of
failure? Well, you know, here, so I outlined some steps here. So step one would be, you know,
really just sit down and imagine it. So the side, what you think your application ought to do,
and you know, don't really fuss too much about what seems practical or what seems likely to work,
just, you know, nobody changed the world saying, I'm not sure that that's going to work. So,
you know, that's step one and then feed that step one forward into a forecasting process. So,
you know, given that, given what you think you want your application to do, figure out what accuracy
will need to achieve your dreams. And if you're not sure, just say 90%. Then, you know, the next step
of our, you know, a recipe for failure would be, well, okay, now we're just going to outsource this.
So, you know, we've thought carefully about what accuracy we want and then, you know,
fortunately, we can use that estimate to somehow figure out how much data we want,
except we kind of can't. So let's just ask for 10,000 rows or something that should do.
And then finally, you know, this is the good part, the part which we all think about a lot for
machine learning projects, you know, it's time to wire everything up, time to implement the model,
time to iterate and fit the model and like, you know, do all of this good stuff. So, you know,
this is the part which we all look forward to and the part that really when people talk about
machine learning projects, this is the phase where, you know, the story starts for most people.
And then finally, you know, okay, hopefully, we can integrate the thing into the project.
And if it doesn't work, then, you know, I hope that we have some, you know, four person who we can
blame. And in turn, might be a good target. Okay, so, you know, let's cut to initially,
what, you know, how does this actually look like? What's going wrong here?
Well, and in particular, you know, I don't want to have this narrative that like, well,
life is hard, failure happens often, like, life is uncertain, and we should just like accept it.
I do think that there's a lot that we can do to minimize this. And so, you know, how can we do
it better? Well, we can start by thinking more broadly about, you know, what makes a successful
machine learning application. And so here I've sort of outlined a little hierarchy of needs.
And at the base of the pyramid, the sort of like thing that you need most, the sort of basic
confident security thing or physical needs is understanding how the model will work into larger
application or the business process. So, you know, basically, this is the planning out of what the
model will do and what need we're trying to get meant for it. And that design question of,
you know, what problem we're going to solve the machine learning is really the fundamental thing.
And if we can have a clarity about that, then we can often find ways to design the problems
so that the problems will be easier to solve from the machine learning perspective. So, you know,
we can make our lives easier and make sure that we're getting technologies that it will be we're
crafting the problem in a way that the technology can easily meet. So then the next step is to take
that business need and map it into annotation schemes and corpus constructions so that we can
decide what the data should look like to actually meet that, to meet the needs that we have.
And in particular, we want to make sure that we're designing the annotation scheme in a way
that facilitates consistent annotations and easy decisions from the models. And this is actually
a lot harder than it sounds, especially for natural language processing because you end up kind of
trying to divide the world into this ontology, right? And the world doesn't actually obey these
fixed-need categories. And so it tends to be quite an art to actually coming up with annotation
schemes and refining them over time that helps the data be consistently annotated and it helps
the model actually do what you want it to do. And then in addition, as well as actually the
annotation scheme, there's an implementation phase of the annotation of, you know, sort of running
the project effectively so that your annotators know what they're doing, so that they're sort of
relatively inconsistently incentivized to give you the sort of annotations that you want to
instant, you've got a good feedback loop through it and also quality control processes. So all of
these things define what the problem you're going to be solving and what data you're going to use
to solve and evaluate it. And then finally, on top of that, that's when we get to this sort of
fun bit of, you know, tensuring your flows and descending your gradients of, you know, deciding your
model architectures and things and then finally optimization as well. And so these, the model
architecture and optimization parts which, you know, the academic community in a lot of tutorials
are focusing on. And this does make sense because in a sense, it is kind of a limiting factor that,
you know, as a global community, we had better solutions to these things. Overall projects would
do better, but in any specific project that you're working with, it's very often the case that
these aren't the things that are going to define success or failure. It's very often the earlier phases
of this that are going to take a project from something that sort of works or something that
really doesn't. So the problem here is that we end up with this chicken and egg problem. So in
order to sort of figure out the product vision that we want, we really often need to know how
accurate the model is likely to be on that problem. So there's a real characteristic difference that
we'll have in the way that we design our application. If we imagine that the model will be say 95%
accurate versus if it's only going to be 80% accurate. And those assumptions and differences are
going to, we really want to bake that back into the way that the whole interaction flow is designed.
For instance, a chat application is probably not going to work very well at all if we're making
an error on every utterance. And, you know, the user has constantly asked for clarification.
If that's going to be a case, then we probably want to design our application differently.
Similarly, for translation, if the translation in our language pair is going to be pretty bad,
then we hope that we could have a lot of dictionary back-offs and lots of ways that we can click
on words to like, you know, help the user puzzle out what's going wrong or what to do if the
translation is bad. And so these, all these things about product design really depend on the
accuracy estimate. And the problem there is that in order to get that sort of reasonable accuracy
estimate, we have to start making contact with the data. We can't really pluck this out of thin air.
And so we need to like start running some experiments. We need to start doing some training
in evaluation. And in order to do that, we need to know what label data could lead. And in order to
do that, we need to know how our annotations should look. But we don't really know how our
annotations should look if we don't know what the model is supposed to do, which feeds back into
the product efficient. So we have this like, you know, this chicken and egg problem of like what
bit to solve first in this. And I think that that actually drives a lot of the problem here.
But okay, so the solution here is that we need to iterate on the whole process. We need to iterate
on the code that we're developing for this and the model architecture and the optimization.
But we also need to iterate on the data that we're developing and the way that we're framing the
problems. So, you know, as we said, like basically don't make assumptions, iterated a more fine
grain level and sort of start going over the feedback more quickly. So we have to figure out what
models we should train to meet the business needs. And then we have to be asking does the
annotation scheme make sense when we start implementing it? And then once we're doing that,
we can figure out this problem look easier or hard. And then we can start moving back to
the business case and saying what can we do in the application to improve the fault tolerance.
So, sort of figure out why this is wrong or where this, you know, basically let's start to look
at where this might go wrong. And, you know, I think this is actually probably the most
interesting case of failure that I think we've observed while running space,
ECM Prodigy and doing our consulting projects. And I think it's one which isn't easily,
isn't often discussed. So, when I say modeling decisions here, I really mean the way to business
requirements are mapped into a set of statistical models. So, you know, we're going to have some
statistical model or combination models that are going to be predicting things. And if we start
off with a sort of need of output, there's often a wide variety of ways that we can break that down
into decisions. So, here, imagine that we want to build a crime database. And it's going to be,
so we're going to be feeding it news reports. And we want to extract the following information.
So, we want to label things like victim name, the name of a perpetrator if it's mentioned,
a crime location if it's mentioned, the date of the offense, date of arrest if it's mentioned,
all of this sort of information. So, this is what we want to output. That's what we want the
sort of system to do. So, how should we break that need down into one or more machine learning models?
And what data should we undertake to train them? How should we evaluate them, et cetera, et cetera?
So, this is what really what I mean by modeling decisions. And the claim that I'm making here is
actually that these decisions are incredibly important, really drive successful failure,
much more than decisions about, you know, using an LSTM versus using a CNN or something like that.
Okay. So, here's one obvious way to do it that I'm going to suggest is probably pretty unideal.
So, imagine that we're going to be labeling these as, you know, basically spans of
text as victim and another span of text as a crime location. And we're going to basically
phrase this as an entity recognition problem. And we're going to train something like a sort of
standard entity recognition model that's going to read the text and try to apply begin inside
and labels to these words. So, this coding clearly can meet the business need.
So, it's clear that, you know, if a classifier could reproduce these annotations accurately,
we can use the annotations that it's producing to meet what we need. The question is,
is this the best way to frame the problem so that it will be cheap to acquire at the annotations
and that the model will perform accurately? And I suggested actually it probably not.
So, here's an alternate way to think about this instead. So, instead of having this sort of
annotation, we might instead do something like this. So, we might apply a bit of information
across a wider span of text. So, we do text classification for crime. And then we might
have a more generic person location, et cetera, tagging. And this doesn't necessarily tag exactly
the same information. So, here, for instance, King Cross is tagged as a location as well as East
London because we're not joining in the coding of the roles that we have here. Like, we're not trying
to figure out that East London was the location of the crime. At this phase of it, we're just tagging
this location. So, the thing to think about here is that we're really making the problem a lot
simpler for each of the models that we're composing together. So, it's a lot simpler to have one
text classification model that tries to decide whether a crime is being discussed,
then to replicate that information across and kind of adjoin it into the entity classifications.
And so, instead of trying to decide at each of these things that, okay, is this a crime location
as well as whether it's a crime, we can factor the information away from each other. And that
is going to make the annotations a lot easier to both annotate and fit it for a model to recognize.
And it will likely take much less annotation to do this if you compose it this way. So,
there's still extra logic that has to be performed to, say, figure out that this person is actually
to victim of the crime as opposed to a perpetrator or some incidental person. But we can do this with
other annotations and other rule-based processes as well. So, here's a quick look at some of the
annotations that Spacey produces that are not problem-dependent. So, these are sort of generic
information that's added as well. So, here we can see that Alex Smith is annotated as a passive
subject of staffed. In other words, he's the person who was staffed and that grammatical relation
there is linked there. So, we could have an extra sort of process that says, okay, something like
a stab and we can build up a lexicon of these sort of victim words. And we can then have a
rule-based process that says, okay, if we've got that sort of crime act and then you take the subject
of it, that's going to be the victim of the crime. Now, I don't want to commit to one specific
plan for these things because the point is that it does have to be experimental, but I hope you
can see that there's a lot of choices here. And making the correct choices on all of these things
is not trivial. So, the correct answer is not to decide everything up front, assume we're right,
and start collecting lots of annotations. We need to start iterating and start seeing what
works for any specific problem. And that's going to, in general, yield a much better, yield much
better results if we take this sort of iterative approach. So, as I said here, to sort of take home
message here is that we often want to be composing generic models and the model solutions. So,
we can have generic categories like location and person. And this lets you use pre-trained models
like Spacy provides. And then, fine-tuning those pre-trained models on your domain is a lot cheaper
than creating annotation data for new categories. And in particular, you don't have this risk of
making new categories, but then you have to refine later and then you have to throw out all the
data that you annotated before. So, life's a lot simpler if you can rely on generic categories
much more than trying to come up with your own. And then, additionally, if you have things like
events or topics and things like this sort of semantic information, I suggest that you usually
think about annotating this at a sentence or paragraph document level rather than trying to fix it
to specific phrases. And the reason is that if you do this as phrase annotations, you very often
have indeterminacies about the boundaries of these things. And especially if the language gets
even slightly metaphorical, trying to figure out exactly which word in a sentence in codes
that a crime was committed ends up being super hard. So, if you want it to be something like,
you know, okay, I just want to know, is it about a crime? You really shouldn't try to put that at
the word level. You should put it at the sentence or paragraph level. And then if you do that,
the annotations easier, the classifications more consistent and easier to learn. And then you can
combine these pieces of information to produce the solutions that you're interested in.
Similarly, if you want something that are sort of like semantic roles or like the person who did
something versus the person who didn't, and you can annotate those things by single words and
then use the syntactic paths to get the boundaries around that. So, you're basically sort of like
having a grid that you're snapping the phrases to. And this makes sure that your boundaries always
make sense. Okay. So, here's a quick look at how this ends up looking, or how does sort of work,
flow looks, if you're using our tool set. So, the Prodigy annotation tool gives you a few commands
that you can basically use to start a little web service locally. And you give it a name of the
data set, and it's going to save that in a little database locally. By default, we use sqlite
to sort of save you from installing extra software. And then you can give it an input data file,
which is by default just formatted in jsonl. It can also read from standard input. And you give it
a label that you might want to annotate. So, in this case, you're going to be get this feed of
data and you can just basically click through whether it's a crime or not. And so, this is super quick
because you're just annotating these short pieces of text like a sentence and applying a binary
label. So, it's pretty normal to be making one of these decisions every five to 10 seconds or so
because you basically have this really simple decision to make. And that means that you can annotate
the data set for that very quickly. And you can build up just enough records to see whether
how accurate that model will be and how simple the task will be very quickly, like, you know,
less than an hour of work and you can have an initial result. Similarly, we have this
teach recipe that lets you improve the accuracy of pre-trained categories. So, you know, you can
feed in a label like personal location. And if there's an initial model that can make those
decisions like, for instance, Spacey provides, you can just use this to sort of fine tune the
accuracy. So, you can tell it whether the model is right or wrong and it will train from that
and basically update its accuracy on this. Then, as a next process, given all of the annotations that
you've provided so far, you can run batch training and, you know, basically see how the accuracy
doesn't try out different hyperparameters and you can do this for the NER as well. And then the
output of all of this is essentially just a model that you can feed into Spacey. So, the Spacey
NLP library lets you just load this up and then you just get basically this function that converts
text into this doc object and the doc object that makes the annotations easy to access. So,
you can do Doc.nence and, you know, assuming everything was correct, you'll get something like
Alex Smith, Rhys London, and these will have the labels that you are interested in attached. So,
Alex Smith hopefully will be labeled as a person. East London hopefully will be labeled as a location.
And then you also get this, there's a text categorization. So, that's accessible at Doc.cats
and that will tell you that it was a crime with, you know, 90% certainty or something like that.
So, the whole workflow here is pretty simple and importantly, we, it's very useful to make
sure that it's outputting a model in the form that you can then easily plug forward into your
production system so that you can start trying this out in the context replication and sort of
both sanity check it and start seeing what would be useful and what isn't. So, you know,
basically try to avoid spending too long in the single sandbox or too long in any one step of
that iterative process. If we can iterate over the hall, all of the steps quicker, then we can
sort of loop back around then sort of progressively improve it. So, rather than spending, you know,
investing huge amounts in an annotation project or design project, you start getting evidence quicker.
And, you know, it's really follows the same sort of logic as other development things where the
waterfall methodology is, tends to perform worse if it's uncertainty than having a sort of
rapid iterative approach. So, and that really feeds into the second problem that I'm basically
going to highlight here and that's that if you really only have an annotation process that's
designed for big annotation projects and you're only thinking about how to scale up and how to
collect tons of data because you assume that that's what you need, then your time to first
bit of evidence is going to be very large and the investment that you need to start collecting
some bit of evidence is going to be very high. And, that's going to be a real problem because
you're going to design this whole big annotation process around assumptions which later may be
unideal. So, instead of just, we want a much more fine ground approach where you can scale down
and get a much, so, and you can start basing your assumptions on contact with data and evidence.
So, we want an easy way to get, say, 200 annotations that you can run an easy process. We want
a process where you can have, say, you know, do one hour of work and get a meaningful, like,
insight into what you should do next and in order to schedule the next five hours of work,
so you can schedule the next 20 hours of work, etc. And, you can always be sort of building
brute strapping that forward based on, you know, contact with the data and evidence instead of
just guesses about what might work. And, this is good because of that fundamental uncertainty
that we have around this. So, if you just make guesses, you're very likely to be wrong.
And, that's why, you know, having a process that scales down, as well as a process that scales
up is so important. And, so, you know, the prescription that we have here is that, you know,
basically even as a data scientist yourself, you know, your job isn't just to, you know,
flow your tenses and design models, you should be doing these annotation projects initially yourself.
And, that is going to give you a much better insight into what's likely to work.
So, as part of your sort of daily workflow, having tooling that makes it easy to start annotating
data to evaluate your ideas and to start, if you have a new idea about, you know, art is product
might, you know, a new machine learning power feature might work in this product or business process.
Instead of sort of coloring management and putting everybody in a room to schedule a meeting
to barrack for your case, you can just start trying it out and you can start seeing whether you're
right that some approach is tractable that a some model will work. And this is going to be
ultimately much more productive, even though it feels like, oh, or wasting time, I'm annotating,
it's much more productive than having an idea for, you know, widening your hidden layers and like,
you know, coding that up and then waiting for that to train, et cetera. The real good leverage
point is going to be in the way that you design the way that you break down the problem into
different machine learning models. And so if you spend much longer, you know, basically figure
out in out that you're annotating the correct things and structuring the project correctly,
you're going to have a much better chance of success. A final tip that I would recommend is this
sort of a bear evaluation. And so this is really a trick that lets you do fine-grained evaluation
without a huge evaluation set. 10? Okay, cool. So what I mean by this is, normally, if you're,
you know, let's say you're interested in figuring out whether some model is 90% accurate
of 91% accurate. Well, in order to sort of figure out that 1% of accuracy, you probably need to
base that decision on about 10 examples. So you need about a thousand annotated examples to
sort of reliably guess that, you know, 1% sensitivity. Well, if instead of that, we do a B
evaluation, we can actually do that much easier. So this is what the A B evaluation looks like,
it, tool looks like in prodigy, and actually it's especially good for genitive
outputs where having a fixed evaluation set is not even very tractable. So imagine that we have
this an image captioning problem, and so we have this image, and we want to know which of these two
outputs is better. So imagine that we've got two models that we're trying to evaluate and compare,
and so one of them has told us that this is a plug and a blanket on the grass, and the other one
has told us that it's an unhappy child in the garden. So clearly, we want to say that this one's
better. And so if we randomly shuffle the order of our system outputs, we can basically just,
you know, A B evaluate this through a few hundred times, and we can do that very quickly.
And this means that even if the models are only slightly different, if they're outputting
the same thing, we get to skip the example. And so you're, and you're very directly saying,
ah, this one or that one is better. And that means that even if you're only making a small tweak,
you can probably evaluate it yourself in about 10 or 20 minutes. You don't need a huge evaluation
set to do this. Now, of course, this isn't as repeatable as a huge evaluation set. And so eventually,
you do want to sort of stable consistent evaluation. But when you're scaling down and you just want to,
you know, basically, be more nimble, this is the A B evaluation is a good approach for a lot of
things. And again, it gives you a good evaluation even on generative outputs instead of relying on
some nonsense, like a blur score or something. Okay. So then a final problem that we, that I want
to highlight is that, you know, even the way that people actually approach annotation is often
pretty bad. And we summarize this problem by saying that it's hard to get good data by boring
to shit out of underpaid people. So if you just put your task on Amazon Mechanical Turk,
there's a whole lot of intermediate problems that you have to solve to actually make sure that
you're going to get quality annotations that you could learn from. And if you don't immediately
get quality annotations that you can learn from, it's very hard to interpret the results and
inspect whether the data was wrong or your model is wrong or like the annotation scheme was wrong
because there's too many explanations for what for the problem. So I would suggest that processes
like Mechanical Turk or other outsourcing based processes that are designed to drive the
and the marginal cost of new annotation towards zero are actually mostly solving the wrong problem.
What you want is a time to first data set and the and a process that's going to be reliable
rather than trying to see it as okay, how much can we pay per individual annotation? The overhead
is actually something that matters a lot more. And so I actually think that for most situations
having a small annotation team working consistently with a good workflow and good communication
with data scientists is usually going to give you better results. And in particular reframing
your problems so that you'll break them down into smaller pieces so that the annotator has to
consider less at a time is also very productive. So the insight here is that the annotators don't
need to have a workflow that exactly matches the way that the model works. So even if the annotators
are sort of seeing a sort of pre-suggested output or pre-field output and the model won't,
that's probably going to be fine and in fact it often makes the annotation more accurate to have
it semi-automatic because if you try to have somebody constantly make the same decision a thousand
times in a row it's very likely that they're going to have some reliability errors and they're going
to have some, make some errors that a machine never would. So for instance if you're tagging parts
of speech you pretty much don't want to have a human annotate every instance of the as and mark
that as a determiner because they're going to be wrong sometimes and when they're wrong they're
probably going to really confuse the model. Whereas if you do that semi-automatically and they only
have to you know basically correct this when it's wrong you're going to have actually more consistent
annotations. Finally I also actually suggested doing annotation in-house and having is good for lots
of reasons and not least of which is data privacy because you don't have this sort of third-party
provider problem who probably wants to be clever and outsourced to data themselves and so then
the text which you know maybe say use a feedback on your product or you know text that was uploaded
into your platform or user messages and things might be getting out to some arbitrary number of
people which even before you know sensible regulations were introduced I actually think is something
that people should definitely worry about and it's like you know not a good look for anybody.
So to wrap this up the solution to this chicken and egg problem is iteration so you know
base and this sort of makes deep sense right like if you can't solve the problem analytically we have
to solve it iteratively like if we can't reason from you know if we've got this sort of circular
dependency and we want to sort of progressively estimate all of these things well we have to just start
make an initial estimate and start feeding that forward and then progressively iterate on this
and you know in the same way that we would do this into you know basically in a machine learning
solution I think the same actually works here it's you know a fundamental thing about the knowledge
being float float around then the the fact that there's this sort of dependency structure
means that actually this is a you know satisfying approach so thanks.
Thanks very much Matt for a very nice talk. Are there any questions in the audience over here?
Thanks for your talk. I just have one question about the screenshot that you displayed there
about Spacey. It's able to detect the text as crime. Is it come automatically from Spacey or you
make some adjustment on it so you maybe fit the label on it? Okay so I'll just go back to the
slide just so that we have a grounding of what we're talking about. So the the process here of the
disk batch train that's outputting a text classification model that can then sort of feed into the
Spacey pipeline and so that sits in the Spacey pipeline and it has the job of taking dock objects
and attaching making predictions based on its neural network model and attaching those predictions
into the dock.cats process. So you can actually you know you could for instance write an arbitrary
function that had that job and it had it to the pipeline or you could write your own machine
learning model but the built-in text categorization system that's Spacey provides uses an ensemble
of the convolutional neural network and a bag of words model and then prodigy trains this
and it outputs it into the model for Spacey to use. So I think the label is in your data set.
So the label the label crime comes in here where we label this and we do this text cat teach that
creates the training data then in this step we train from the training data outputting a model.
We use that model as the input into this any our batch train process and that carries forward the
text cat model into the full model that's output here and then we load the full model and that's
how the data flows around. Okay yes in the back. Okay yeah you set some like you made the
example to some like extract the victim and maybe also the murderer of a crime and for that you
set maybe use the dependency parser but the dependency parser tends to some like it considerably
worse if some like your corpus has a different structure than the dependency parser was originally
trained on so normally dependency parser has an accuracy of 93% or something like that but I can
see often that it gets down to something like 60% on some like very different colloquial speech
so how would you treat a problem like that. So this is definitely a concern and in particular
I would say that it's often hard to reason about or hard to guess how useful the dependency
parser would be before you start trying things out. So if it is the case that you'd like to use
and the accuracy isn't high enough having this sort of training process where you you know
are basically improving the accuracy of it on your domain is something that we're we definitely
see a solution going forward. So the dependency sort of recipes in prodigy are still a little bit
in beta form but you can already use this to you know start making some corrections to the dependency
if it is the case that the dependency parser doesn't do what you want then actually having
another model that is basically only constrained to work on the person category I would say is
probably going to be a better approach. So in other words you could classify only to person
entities and apply some sort of more specific model based on that for whether it is a victim.
Another option would be that you might have a sort of fixed number of frames that you know
basically predicate argument structures for like you know shapes at which to sort of these
relationships between victim perpetrator etc. And if that's the case then you can classify this
you can tag the sentence with those things instead of relying on the dependency parser's features.
Finally you can also reduce the sentence and train your own sort of little parse tree over
just the sentence, just the input pieces which are useful. So you basically get just to use
the tree building technology and train that yourself and because that's working on such a reduced
problem level and you can abstract the English so much that may also be easy to try.
May also be easy to train. So there's a sort of range of options that you can sort of think about
and explore that will depend on the specific sort of problem but I would definitely say that
it's not something where you just know ahead of time that like this is the one way to do it.
Let's invest everything in this. You should you know explore these things and iterate.
Yes. Sure.
Hi so you mentioned a dependency parser recipe. Do you see a more generic
just link prediction recipe in the future? So you can you can definitely use the tooling
there for sort of more generic link annotations. The only sort of coupling with the recipe
there is that you know we wanted to have the pre-trained model there and you know have that sort
of suggesting the links and things. So because the pre-trained models that we provide do you know
basically this syntactic structure there's a question of how you will sort of get the initial
suggestions if you're doing it that way. But if you have some process that basically suggests
links for you you can certainly just pipe those into production and say yes or no to them.
That's no problem. We have time for one last question.
Over there I think it was first.
So I have a question in terms of the features that currently you guys are looking at which is
very focused on the text. Is there any focus towards other types of features that maybe in the
either visual or positional or formatting sense when processing things like documents or images
with text. Are you guys looking to also use space or one of these frameworks to be able to
extract these features and and load them and be able to analyze them even with with
prodigy like PDFs etc. So this has come up a bit over the last few months and so it's
definitely something that we've been thinking about. I think the solution that I think is
probably best is that you feed the the output of say a more you know text-focused model forwarders
features into a downstream model which combines information from different sources. So you know
as an example of the type of thing which is coming up people might have want to do named entity
recognition. There's some metadata or attached to the article or something like you know maybe
topic categories or something like this and they want to use those features to improve the
accuracy of the entity recognition which is you know a very reasonable thing to want to do.
So rather than having a general purpose way of putting those features into the entity recognition
model and kind of trying to retrain with new features I think it's actually better to do it
sort of the inverse and take the output of the entity recognition model and feed that forward
into a next level model and I think that'll make it easier to for us to you know be providing
something which is reusable across different things and also that you can sort of really write
arbitrary features yourself rather than having to be limited to whatever feature API we ended up
trying to expose to make a compromise for that. So I think that that's probably the best way to
make that happen. Okay let's thank Joseby Curian.